Finally, you don't have to lay eyes on an ad or a baby, or an ad about a baby...
...or wonder if you should unfriend that lady from high school...
...but you're not sure if she'll get upset.
No, these mildly annoying issues are ones that you never have to worry about again.
You see, two things separate Ello from other social networking sites.
One, there are no ads, and two, it's invite only.
You either know someone already on the network or you request an invitation.
Ello was created by a US collective of artists and designers a few months ago.
The reason, according to its manifesto, is this:...
..."We believe in audacity."
"We believe in beauty, simplicity and transparency."
Ello capitalizes on Facebook's faults, priding itself on less ads and more privacy.
You don't need a real name to sign up...
...and you can disable the company's analytics software.
It makes money by charging users for additional features...
...and it has a very minimalist interface, kind of like a Tumblr-Twitter hybrid.
You can post pics, links, vids, vines, whatever.
The news feed is filtered into two streams: friends and noise.
Oh, and there's no "Like" button.